glad you're glad the baby's okay you
know that's terrifying
absolutely can walk right into your
house right all right
one american plans to vote in the
upcoming election even though she'll be
more than 200 miles above
earth on november 3rd check this out i
think it's really important for
everybody to vote and if we can do it
from space
then i believe folks can do it from the
ground too that is astronaut kate rubins
she is training for a mid-october launch
to the international space station most
u.s astronauts
live in houston texas law allows them to
vote from
space using a secure electronic
ballot this is cool she's not the first
one to do this but this is very cool
that she thinks this is such a
consequential
election that she's going to cast that
ballot the first was actually back in
1997.
i love that we can figure out how to get
people to vote from space but we
struggle down here on earth
that is the ultimate folks you know that
is the ultimate if i can vote from space
you can vote down here well the space
program has invented many things that we
use every day
perhaps secure